hello and Walker to this video playing
victory 16 Australia okay so what can I
do here
yeah I've experimented with this move
but simply ignoring at it okay and it
looks a little bit okay it just goes
back that's unexpected
yeah now I can just do this and double
attack the g8 so well I can take c5 but
if I go Knight g5 what's about this h7
pawn we can win that that would be nice
yeah I can still take h7
[Music]
don't see that too often a window age
seven pol and have a pawn already on age
six okay so I probably take it now what
to do now I can just trade that wouldn't
be bad but III is also looking quite
good and just get the center get the
center with default still difficult to M
to get to that porn you should see for
six Chetna degree six
rooty 195 threatening d5 doesn't react
to it 40 Hatter
somehow okay maybe this is an idea
actually 95 but I can actually do this
young check check now f450 794 looks a
little bit annoying though
I can still move it I could move the
bishop on me okay okay
can i play for meit king of 290x King f3
that slip made is unavoidable bit a bit
bit of fancy play though right it's okay
right I mean you cannot take it and King
f3 what I will stop the made its made
g5g for checking g6 f5 made can almost
provoke you for him you can actually do
it
black resigns Janet that opening worked
well would you did yeah I think 96 is
good yeah I'm not sure about this I
don't know if you want to go back
release and this I mean the engine wants
to play efore which makes sense I was
also thinking this could make make some
sense look at this look at this okay and
he went back now probably is six and
this this looks comfortable
yeah f6 probably has to be played after
this it's it's basically over I just
wonder if I'm check late this correctly
check check check
we're gonna mess up something Jeff but
it seems to be okay can I look h4
strongly edgy for me okay when the best
that you can do is some rook moves to b8
after which I'm also much better you
form okay okay yeah I think it was okay
thanks for watching